most palestinians have never left gaza
because they're not allowed to
so when israel recently said it would
grant a few hundred work permits this is
what happened
it's not quite a matter of life or death
but it's not far from
[Applause]
gaza five months after the war ended is
still a land of rubble and fear
the ceasefire between israel and hamas
the militant organization which controls
gaza
is fragile but it is just about holding
for now
but in their first interview since
mediation talks in egypt ended hamas has
told sky news that they will continue to
fight israel
we can defeat israel we can't target
israel i think we targeted so many times
okay we can't kill they can come and
destroy everything but in the same time
we israel will never see the stability
unless the palestinians get their
stability and their security
they have to understand this you'll
continue to fight israel you'll continue
to strike israel yes it is all right
national rights
if that happens there will be more
scenes like this
six-year-old susie was rescued holding
the body of her younger brother her
apartment block was hit by an israeli
missile during the recent conflict
her two sisters her two brothers and her
mother died in the airstrike
[Applause]
this patch of sand is what is left of
their home today
israel said that it was targeting hamas
tunnels nearby
and that their deaths were unintended
susie is traumatized she plays alone she
barely speaks
and she wakes screaming in the night
her father dreads another war
butler
foreign
[Music]
the victims of the actions of both sides
in this ongoing conflict
right now the chances of a lasting truth
seem
pretty small
on the one hand both sides say that they
want peace and it is not in their
interests to start another conflict
but on the other hand neither side can
agree on a way that they can live
together on the same piece of land
and as long as that difference remains
another war seems
inevitable
for now life in gaza has returned to its
unique version of normality
they know it might not last long
israeli drones constantly circle
overhead watching
always watching
alistar bunco sky news gaza